going back to something you just said
I'm curious your opinion on this having
worked with so many different directors
do you think it's important for a Star
Wars feature film director to be a fan
because I was also just i believe i was
watching or reading something with ron
howard where he said he was approaching
it more as like a casual fan they do you
think you need to know the ins and outs
in order to dread one of these movies i
don't think you need i mean working with
ron howard on solo was one of the my
favorite experiences ever working in
film the man is a consummate
professional totally understands that
filmmaking is actually fun what we do
we're working on movies we're not you
know having to save lives or something
we're like working on films and he
understands we all have a life outside
of the job so he lets us have you know
we don't work a lot of overtime and you
know the first time i met him
i'd met him a couple times socially but
the first time I met him professionally
we sat down and had this great meeting
about what he wanted the movie to be and
he says he would give a lot of trust in
the artist saying you know we'd get into
his own here's the story points I want
to hit and I'm trusting you guys to
guide me that it's in the Star Wars
Pantheon that it's gonna if there's
something that I could do to tweak it to
make it just right for Star Wars I'm
entrusting upon the story group and all
these artists that have been working
with me to bring us there and so they
don't need to be they don't need to know
every single planet and name of every
single person but there's a group of
people are Lucasfilm story group and the
artists that work on the films that are
there to do that for him and so but you
can have other fans that completely know
it like Dave Filoni that I work with
like the you know he's completely he's
been trained from George Lucas and he's
an uber fan so he knows everything so
that's a bonus so that's just all its
its it you can do it any other way any
way you want but Ron super professional
and one of my favorite experiences and
yet I think casual fan is a good way to
say that yeah you guys have name-dropped
so many cool people from Kathleen
Kennedy to George Lucas to Dave Filoni
as well is there anyone kind of on that
tier of the Star Wars franchise that has
ever given you a piece of advice about
telling a Star Wars story that's really
stuck with you
well Phil O'Neill Ickes and George both
were very much they like to tie things
and submit they're very much into the
the joseph campbell power of myth and
and and restore the the story of the
hero's journey and all that so when you
can tie your story into something that's
greater than that moments they're very
much into that that's that's that's one
of the big pieces of advice that I've
been given and and when we try to you
know you we did all the even though I
work in sound it's still a very
inclusive project and I'm having to
re-record a bunch of the actors and and
and you can come up especially a lot of
characters that have masks on like
stormtroopers like Boba Fett like kylo
Ren you can change your dialogue to fit
better at later on in post-production so
there's a lot of Star Wars movies are
made in post-production a lot of it the
editorial process the visual effects the
sound the music it's all done after the
shooting so it's all honing that film
and to tell the story that the director
wanted with sound and visual effects so
lotta after after you've shot yeah this
is almost about the same amount of time
it's about it's about a year's worth of
post that you do on a movie a film you
post for me I never realized at the time
being so young and not knowing what Star
Wars was when I became full effect I was
getting taught by the man himself the
author the Creator
the one man George Lucas and although he
didn't spend much time giving directions
to the other adults he spent a lot of
time showing me and teaching me what he
wanted me to see like instead of being
like oh hey you're gonna be flying a
spaceship and there's gonna be like
these rocks coming at you he's like oh
so you're gonna come back next week and
we're gonna fly through an asteroid and
there's gonna be these boulders are
gonna come at you and there's gonna be a
Jedi chasing you and you guys is gonna
be flying after me can you do that I'm
like how cool is this job right
so now being a grown man and having a
kid of my own I look back at those
experiences in that time not realizing
that I had something a one-on-one
interaction connection with this one man
that you know many people will never
ever get now especially in the Star Wars
world you know and I will forever be
able to die and and take every single
direction and and what he helped me to
bring Boba Fett to life on stage